SOWMYA SUBRAMANIAN:
Good morning.
Thank you for joining
us today to celebrate
International Women's Day.
This is a global
event, so I want
to encourage you
throughout the day
to use the social media
to express your voice.
Please use #WomenTechMakers.
I'm super excited to
be part of this event.
I'm here because,
like many of you,
I have a degree in
computer science.
A master's in computer
science from University
of Wisconsin-Madison,
and a bachelor's
from Mount Holyoke College.
Also I've been in the
industry for 15 years,
since I graduated.
And one of the senior
women engineers
in YouTube engineering.
And I love being in technology.
This is not always the case.
Many women drop out of
technology in school,
or even after they
start their career.
Nearly 50% of women
within the first 10 years
of their technical carrier
either switch professions
or quit.
I have not, and I'm confident
each and every one of you,
after listening to the
great lineup of speakers
we have today and the events we
have planned, will not either.
As technologists and thinkers,
we solve everyday problems,
and we come up with innovative
ways to make things happen.
Women make up 51% of
the world's population.
Yet, according to the
Department of Commerce,
women make up only 27% of
all computer science jobs
in the US.
And these numbers are worse when
it comes to leadership roles.
Women are part of 14% of Fortune
500 executive committees,
17% of Congress, and
11% of founder or CEO
positions in venture-backed
[? packed ?] US firms.
The number of women
studying computer science
is on the decline.
It's nearly 8% below where
we were nearly 10 years ago,
and this is important.
It's important to note
and recognize this,
because time and
time again we have
seen that diverse and
well-balanced teams result
in more effective decision
making, and in better product
designs.
According to McKinsey,
companies which
have a higher proportion of
women in top management roles
result in higher
returns on investment,
and bigger, higher
earnings than average.
Catalyst found
out that companies
which have at least
three women as part
of their board of
directors have on average
10% return on investment
compared to only 6.2%
otherwise.
Universities and companies
are recognizing this,
and doing their part
to help bridge the gap.
For instance, Google provides
a great work environment
for women.
Has strong women leaders
to serve as role models
within the company, many of whom
you will be hearing from today.
The women at Google
Network of over 5,000
women from 23 countries
is very active.
And Google helps
organize events like this
to raise gender awareness.
We also, as part of our
commitment to advancing
computing and technology
at all levels,
we have education and research
and scholarship programs
for aspiring
computer scientists.
Our generation for
Google scholarships
are aimed at currently
enrolled high school
seniors, undergraduates,
and graduates
who are planning to
be full time enrolled
students in universities
in the US or Canada.
The Anita Borg
scholarship is for women
across the world
who are pursuing
a degree in computer science.
And the Women on the Web
program-- which started out
as a community based
initiative to encourage
more women participation in
Google for Business groups--
aimed at increasing the
number of women entrepreneurs
in technology,
and enabling women
to succeed by leveraging
the power of the internet
early on in their startups.
This program that
started out in India
has now expanded to
Latin America, Africa,
southeast Asia, and middle east.
And it focuses on encouraging
women and empowering them
in emerging markets.
From the very beginning
Google's mission has been,
and goal has been,
and the mantra
has been, focus on the user
and all else will follow.
It turns out our
users are 50% women,
speak different
languages, and come
from different
parts of the world.
And in order to better
understand this diverse user
space, and build great
products and services for them,
we need our teams
to be diverse too.
So Google puts in
a lot of effort
to ensure that we have an
all inclusive workplace.
And that we reflect
what our users are,
so that we can build out
better products and services.
We also are proactively
looking at ways
in which we can make
the environment better,
and empower women further.
For instance, recently our
focus on unconscious bias.
Research has shown
that when we are
aware of our
unconscious bias, we
can make more
objective decisions
and have better discussions.
So over 20,000 Googlers
and 80% people managers
have been engaging
in workshops focused
on understanding the science
of how the mind works
to bring together
and have dialogues
across the company about
the unconscious bias
and the effect it has on how
we perceive others; how we
interact with our coworkers,
our clients, and the business
as a whole.
Efforts like this allow us to
make ourselves into a better
company, and become a better
workplace environment.
In honor of International
Women's Day,
Google offices
all over the world
have been hosting
events like this.
I was honored to be a speaker
at the International Women's Day
event in Paris just
this past Wednesday
to around 200-plus attendees.
It was invigorating and very
energizing to see and hear
people's aspirations and
dreams in those attendees.
And also to hear
stories from them
on how the number of
women in computer science
has been increasing in local
colleges and universities.
So these efforts that
we're doing is paying off.
In fact recently, when I was
getting ready for these talks,
I found out that in
2014, for the first time
in the history of University
of California, Berkeley,
an introductory
computer science class
has more women
enrolled than men.
[APPLAUSE]
And the slight change,
the slight positive trend,
is significant for women
in computer science
and women in technology.
So we have a great, great
agenda planned for you
with amazing
speakers, some of whom
I have the honor of
working closely with.
And I'm confident by hearing
the inspiring talks from them,
by engaging and networking
with all the different women
engineers who are
here at the event,
you will end the day
even more energized,
ready to go change the world,
and make things happen.
[APPLAUSE]